c'est à chambray-lès-tours au centre de
traitement et de régulation de
l'alertent que romain travaille depuis
2016 un reclassement comme agents
techniques et administratifs pour ce
pompier devenu tétraplégique à la suite
d'une chute de ski en 2012 pompiers et
samu bonjour oui une vie de pompier de
sportifs en touraine puis en
haute-savoie brutalement stoppée depuis
l'accident une seconde vie à
reconstruire apprivoiser c'est un dur de
se dire que je pourrais peut être
pompier est au départ c'est un petit peu
compliqué moi je vous voyez que par ça
je voyais pas d'autres traces d'autres
métiers après le sport ça a toujours été
un moteur même avant voilà c'était pas
une raison de vivre mais j'en avais
besoin
j'en avais besoin pour être bien et
d'autant plus depuis que je suis en
fauteuil roulant depuis qu'il est revenu
en touraine travail et retrouver sa
fille
romain s'est lancé un défi un rêve
participer aux jeux paralympiques de
tokyo en 2020 depuis plusieurs mois ils
s'entraînent quatre fois par semaine
soutenu et encouragé par ses collègues
il a créé une association
le rêve de romain je me suis dit quitte
à se lancer dans quelque chose autant le
faire à fond parce que je suis comme ça
en général dans la vie quand je fais
quelque chose j'aime bien aller au fond
des choses et puis c'était aussi une
façon de montrer que c'est pas parce
qu'on a des difficultés dans la vie on
peut se relever toutes les difficultés
il faut juste en avoir l'envi faut avoir
la volonté se donner les moyens et c'est
pour ça que je pense à la base c'est
faire passer le message à ma fille
surtout et aussi à tout le monde que
voilà on peut on peut réaliser nos rêves
il faut se donner les moyens mais par
contre effectivement des fois on a
besoin d'un petit connu c'est marie qui
a prêté main forte à romain pour
développer son site contacter des
entreprises et lancé une cagnotte
participative car le fauteuil
d'athlétisme indispensable et adapté au
handicap de romain coûte autour de 9000
euros
c'est un rêve pour romain mais c'est
aussi un message d'espoir pour tout le
monde on arrête de mettre les personnes
handicapées quel que soit leur handicap
à un rang de personnes autres c'est des
gens comme tout le monde
au contraire je pense qu'ils ont plus
d'état un état d'esprit beaucoup plus
important
beaucoup plus fort puma la preuve au
moins il se bat tous les jours il arrive
aujourd'hui à travailler comme tout le
monde il fait du sport comme tout le
monde veut faire du sport rien que marc
est juste le financier et là on est là
pour l'aider bon eh ouais pour revenir à
ce même principe les ss on va essayer de
travailler à ses côtés
voilà regarde devant tokyo
là bas romain lui va devoir se surpasser
physiquement pour atteindre les minima
français puis internationaux sur 100 200
400 m c'est avec de jeunes athlètes
handisport et son coach qui s'entraînent
entre douleur et bonne humeur
ils viennent tous avec des rêves moi ce
que je leur dis tous c'est que je vais
le ramener sur le plus haut niveau lors
leur haut niveau
si l'heureux haut niveau c'est une
qualification une sélection sur les jeux
paralympiques
si c'est une médaille sur les jeux
paralympiques tant mieux en tout cas ça
veut dire qu'on aura on aura bien
travaillé un pour moi je faire du sport
à la faire du sport c'est souffrir
pendant l'effort c'est assez c'est à ce
moment là où le handicap pour le maître
côté parce que on peut faire du sport on
peut se faire mal comme un sportif
lambda et moi c'est du plaisir mais si
effectivement on souffre mais c'est le
but du jeu par contre heureusement qu'il
ya des gens pour m'aider parce que
effectivement et de la manutention il ya
plein de choses à faire que je peux pas
faire tout seul
romain passé des années à se courir les
autres aujourd'hui il a besoin de leur
soutien pour réaliser son rêve
une aventure humaine a partagé avec
l'association lorraine de romain